I love that sound
Randy and I share the exact same DNA
which means I could kill and he could
take credit for it which is exactly what
happens whenever we do stand-up comedy
Jason had a hemorrhoid surgery that
didn't work okay
so win or lose tonight his ass is
getting creamed you're you're like my
hemorrhoids your shitty and I can't get
rid of you yeah and and yet somehow
you're a giant pain in my okay okay can
I do my job do it Randy was raised as a
Jew spoiler alert then he married a Jew
and for some reason they have a
Christmas tree in their house every year
which i think is funny and I remember
one time he asked me where he should put
the tree and I said put it under the
photo of our grandparents who hid during
the Holocaust
a lot of people ask us how do you tell
the two of us apart I say it's easy
Jason's the one in glasses and I'm the
one in a good marriage
[Applause]
all right we're going there I didn't
realize we're going there I want to say
something that he doesn't want you to
know randy has been cheating on his wife
for the past 20 years he's been openly
my career when we were born
Jason came five minutes early which is
funny because he still does that every
time he's inside a woman a lot of people
ask me if Randy was dying would I feel
it and I'm like yeah that's why I won't
let him do stand-up by himself I guess
you should wish congratulations to Jason
LA Weekly just rated him the third
funniest Sklar twin
[Applause]
every time Randi and I have auditioned
against each other I've won the role so
yeah so basically he's gonna get another
acting gig when Kevin Spacey gets a Kids
Choice Award people ask us if we're
twins
do we have a psychic connection I say
yes I can already tell that Jason's
gonna die alone
[Applause]